what we're going to do in this video is
learn to construct congruent angles and
we're going to do it with of course a
pen or a pencil here i'm going to use a
ruler as a straight edge and then i'm
going to use a tool known as a compass
which looks a little bit fancy but what
it allows us to do and we'll apply using
it in a little bit it allows us to draw
perfect circles or arcs of a given
radius you pivot on one point here and
then you use your pen or your pencil to
to trace out the arc or the circle so
let's just start with
this angle right over here and i'm going
to construct an angle that is congruent
to it so let me make the vertex of my
second angle right over there and then
let me draw one of the rays
that originates at that vertex and i'm
going to put this angle in a different
orientation just to show that they don't
even have to have the same orientation
so it's going to look something
like that that's one of the rays but
then we have to figure out where we put
where do we put the other ray so that
the two angles are congruent and this is
where our compass is going to be really
useful
so what i'm going to do is put the
pivot point of a compass of the compass
right at the vertex of the first angle
and i'm going to
draw out an arc
like this and what's useful about the
compass is you can make you can keep the
radius constant
and you can see it intersects our first
two rays at points let's just call this
b
and c and i could call this point a
right over here
and so let me now that i have my compass
with the exact right radius right now
let me draw that right over here
but this alone won't allow us to draw
the angle just yet
but let me draw it like this
and that is pretty good
and let's call
this point right over here d i know i'll
call this one e and i want to figure out
where to put my third point f so i can
define ray ef so that these two angles
are congruent and what i can do is
take my compass again
and
get a clear
sense of the distance between c and b by
adjusting my compass
so one point is on c and my pencil is on
b
so i have
get this right so i have this distance
right over here
i know this distance
and i've adjusted my compass accordingly
so i can get that same distance
right over there
and so you can now imagine where i'm
going to draw that second ray that
second ray
if i put
point f
right over here
my second ray i can just draw
between starting at point e right over
here going through
point f i could draw that a little bit
neater
so it would look like that my second ray
ignore that first little line i drew i'm
using a pen which i don't recommend for
you to do it i'm doing it so that you
can see it on this video
now how do we know that this angle is
now congruent to this angle right over
here
well one way to do it is to think about
triangle bac
triangle bac and triangle let's just
call it dfe
so this triangle right over here
when we drew that first arc we know that
the distance between ac
is equivalent to the distance between a
b
and we kept the compass radius the same
so we know that's also the distance
between e f and the distance between e d
and then the second time when we
adjusted our compass radius
we now know that the distance between bc
is the same as the distance between
f and d or the length of bc is the same
as the length of fd
so it's very clear that we have
congruent triangles all of the three
sides have the same measure
and therefore the corresponding angles
must be congruent as well